entre este viernes o el próximo lunes la
subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales del parlamento peruano
debe oficializar y a su vez aprobar por
votación este reporte que será para
aprobado será trasladado a la comisión
permanente del congreso y ésta a su vez
la trasladará al pleno del parlamento
peruano donde se necesitan 66 votos en
el informe de 89 páginas se establece
que el presidente pedro casio habría
transgredido la constitución política
peruana wilson soto uno de los autores
de este reporte señala que el mandatario
peruano habría violentado la soberanía
de este país así como los límites que
tiene perú con las naciones vecinas el
mandatario peruano está en estos
momentos en el sur del país no ha
querido él formular ninguna declaración
hasta el momento este caso lo pone en
serios aprietos al haber ofrecido en una
entrevista otorgar una salida al mar
para bolivia
no hay declaraciones por tanto de
castillo pero que otras reacciones ha
provocado este informe preliminar que
además de juicio político también
recomienda la inhabilitación del
presidente
benji espinoza abogado del presidente
pedro castillo ha rechazado el reporte
congresal afirma que no tiene ningún
sustento jurídico por su parte la
vicepresidenta peruana dina baluarte ha
dicho que esta acusación no está
justificado con ningún sustento
constitucional en realidad el panorama
para el mandatario peruano se complica
porque el próximo viernes debe acudir a
la fiscalía donde sería interrogado
nuevamente por investigaciones por
presunta corrupción